what will happen to the stock market
what should I do with my stimulus check
will the economy recover everyone is
Sally Krawczyk CEO and co-founder Pella
vest the investing platform built by
women for women and today I'm going to
answer some of your most commonly
googled questions about the stock market
and the economy who gets stimulus money
well I hope you do you can receive up to
$1,200 plus $500 for each dependent
child and you'll receive a stimulus
check if you have a social security
number and you file taxes in 2018 or
2019 and if you don't the part enough to
file taxes you can get it if you receive
Social Security payments now you get a
payment it's on a sliding scale a little
complicated because it's the government
but you receive a payment if you earn
less than 99 thousand dollars if you're
a single filer if you earn less than one
hundred thirty six thousand dollars five
hundred for head of household or less
than one hundred ninety-eight thousand
dollars for married file or in your most
recent tax return what should I do with
my stimulus check well in theory you
should do whatever you want with it the
government sent that money out with no
strings attached
so that you could spend it so that they
could stimulate the economy that's why
it's called stimulus money now what do I
hope that you will do with it I hope
that if you have credit card debt
outstanding or other high interest rate
debt and you'll take this money and pay
some portion of that off its high
interest rate it tends to SAP your
wealth it's very expensive
I also hope if you don't have savings
what we call an emergency fund that's
the equivalent of several months of
take-home pay but then you'll put this
into savings and have that there as a
cushion for yourself
I also hope you'll put it in your 401k
and invest for future you or invest for
a future goal but it really is in order
to stimulate the economy and so I know
the government and small businesses will
be perfectly happy if you go out and
spend it what will happen to the stock
market bottom line in the short to
medium term nobody knows I don't care
how confident they sound I don't care
how often they tell you how right they
have been historically
nobody can predictably forecast the
performance of the stock market or
individual stocks over the short to
medium term they're just too many
factors that drive it
one of which very importantly is that
stock prices aren't reflective of just
what's happened in the past which is
pretty easily analyzable they also are
reflections of what expectations are for
the future and so the expectations the
future can change on any given day they
can be wrong they can be right and
that's what makes stock prices move now
what I can tell you is that over the
long term since the 1920s the stock
market has gone up about nine point
seven percent a year
that's quite attractive and that is
despite world war two the Great
Depression the Vietnam War the Korean
War stagflation inflation oil crisis the
Great Recession the internet bubble
burst that even with these tough things
that have happened to our economy the
economy is such that it continues to
grow over periods of time and the stock
market continues to reflect that even
during tough times it's been upward
trending with volatility around that
trend
why is gas so cheap prices are set by
supply and demand if there's a lot of
demand for something people really want
something but there's not a lot of
supply there's not a lot of it prices go
up if instead there's not much demand
say people aren't in their cars they're
sheltering in place they're not
traveling they're not going many places
then and there's a lot of supply then
prices go down
that's why gas prices are low right now
is it a good idea to buy a house right
now okay if you're asking because you
think house prices are a little soft and
you can buy one and potentially flip it
and make money please don't
if you are looking for a home for you to
live in and for your family to live in
it could be a good time to buy right now
if you're in good shape financially have
you paid off your high interest rate
debt your credit card debt for example
have you built an emergency fund that
some months of take-home pay is a safety
net is the company you're working for in
pretty good financial shape are they
getting through this downturn well if
you can answer yes to all of that then
if you can afford a down payment for the
home that you love that's 20% of the
home's value so you don't take a big
mortgage relative to it then this could
be a good time to buy a home is it a
good idea to buy stocks no historically
it's almost always a good idea to buy
stocks right now if you can invest in
those stocks and leave that money there
for the long term say 15 years you'd
invested on any day since the 1920s and
left the money in the stock market
broad-based diversified portfolio the
stock market for 15 years your chances
even with all the ups and downs of a
positive return or 99% will the housing
market crash I'm not gonna lie it could
I'm not saying it will but of course
it's a possibility as people earn less
potentially can't pay their mortgage
potentially have to sell it fire sale
prices and have to do it at the same
time a lot of other people perhaps have
lost their jobs and aren't feeling
confident about buying now it is
instructed to look at the last housing
market crash it was driven by over
leveraged which were people buying big
homes with big mortgages and when the
prices of homes started to soften the
house value goes down but the mortgage
doesn't and so these individuals ended
up underwater pretty quickly they're
poor tried to panic sell couldn't find a
market for it this downturn is driven by
a virus not over leveraged in the
mortgage markets people having big
mortgages and so what's really going to
matter here and the depth and the length
of the recession and how quickly we
recover should I invest in oil done now
the answers are it depends and yes if
you're thinking about is a short term
play a short term bet then sure we
talked earlier about how no one can
forecast accurately where the market or
sector is going over the shorter medium
term so take the money you would have
taken to the trip
to Vegas that got canceled and go ahead
and make that bet on oil stocks if you
want the other answer is yes if you're
thinking about investing in oil stocks
is part of a long term diversified
investment portfolio stocks bonds a
range of different industries and the
answer to my mind is always yes what
happens in a recession a recession is
defined as six months or more of
economic contraction or negative
economic growth can last for six months
or can last four years in a recession
companies tend to sell less they those
can lose money they does let cut back on
spending people lose their jobs house
prices can go down the stock market can
go down will be affected by a recession
the answer is everyone can be though of
course to different extents and you can
see how these things can sort of become
self reinforcing spirals where if
businesses are selling less and then
they're firing people are reducing pay
and then the consumer isn't doesn't feel
as good so it doesn't buy as much so the
company sells less so reduces pay so the
consumer doesn't feel as good and so the
effective recession can be self
reinforcing and that's why you often
hear as you're in this downturn about
economic stimulus where the government
steps in with tax cuts or interest rate
decreases in order to put more money in
the consumers pocket in order to incur
in this case businesses pockets in order
to encourage them the consumer to spend
more and the business to keep people
employed will the economy recover the
economy has recovered from every
economic recession and economic
depression 100% of them and we can
criticize capitalism for any number of
things but its ability to drive growth
to drive recovery is second to none
should I pay my red the answer is if you
can afford to absolutely if you can't
afford to call your landlord and see
what the two of you can work out after
you hang up with him or her call the
utility company called the electricity
company call the cable company called a
cell phone company call your student
loan provider call the credit card
company call call call
spend that time calling you never know
the answer maybe no but by spending the
time more and more of these companies
recognizing the shape the economy's in
the shape that consumers in are really
working with consumers today in order to
work out different blame payment plans
or defer payments I hope that answers
your questions maybe your concerns about
the stock market and about the economy
I'd invite you to come over to LMS combo
to learn more about LMS as well as go to
our magazine page where we've got a ton
of information about all things money
and particularly as we're going through
this downturn a lot of information to
work to help you navigate it if I didn't
answer your question you don't see it
there email us at questions at LMS com
we are committed to answering every
money question that our broader
community has for us as we all navigate
through this time
[Music]